[Musica]
[Applauso]
il 24 marzo del 2019
siamo allo stadium di torino
scontro al vertice del campionato di
serie a di calcio femminile
juventus fiorentina quindi non una
semplice partita ma la partita ed è
incredibile perché le squadre stanno per
fare il loro ingresso in campo e ho il
tempo di incrociare lo sguardo delle
giocatrici lo sguardo fiero orgoglioso e
gli occhi sono pieni di gioia così come
sono i miei occhi pieni di gioia perché
rialzo verso gli spalti e realizzo i
40.000 spettatori 40 mila un record
assoluto in italia per una partita di
calcio femminile
e pensare che nei giorni che precedevano
l'incontro a tutti noi speravamo 10 mila
spettatori
forse i più ottimisti 15.000 invece no
erano proprio 40.000 e c'erano proprio
tutti i nostri tifosi con le bandiere
tantissime famiglie con i bambini
giocatrici ex giocatrici scuole calcio
c'erano persino i curiosi gli scettici o
chi molto più semplicemente non aveva
mai messo piede dentro uno stadio
c'erano anche i tifosi avversari che
partecipavano alla ola alla classica olà
insieme a tutti ed era bellissima si
respirava un clima di festa
pazzesco ed è stato come vivere un
bellissimo film la cui sceneggiatura
però è stata scritta molto tempo prima
tempo in cui il calcio femminile
nonostante mettesse successi vacillava
comunque nell'oblio e per me rievocare
quei ricordi e stato veramente un attimo
e allora con la mente mi porto indietro
il tempo nel tempo in cui chi si
presenta un'opportunità per la tua vita
opportunità di cambiare tutto
l'opportunità in cui capisci veramente
chi sei e dove vuoi andare e il 24
novembre del 1991
ci troviamo in cina iad man per i quarti
di finale del primo campionato del mondo
di calcio femminile noi l'italia
giochiamo contro la norvegia e siamo
sotto di due a uno e da lì a poco avrei
fatto il mio ingresso in campo la mia
prima presenza in nazionale devo
ammettere che far parte di questa
spedizione azzurra fu per me quasi per
caso una fortuna sì perché nei giorni
precedenti la partenza la spedizione
azzurra si fece male uno dei pilastri
della nazionale maggiore
e così fu ripescata io dall'under 21 per
prendere il suo posto
quindi mi si presenta un'opportunità
incredibile la colgo al volo con
entusiasmo ma devo dire che una volta
arrivati da in cina non fu mai preso in
considerazione tanti allenamenti e tanto
sudore tanti tanta frustrazione anche
quella sensazione di inadeguatezza ma
cosa ci faccio io qui e dire che pensavo
di essere forte essere brava ma in
realtà e rossi un talento ma che aveva
ancora tutto da imparare e guardando le
altre giocare in quel momento ho capito
chi ero e ho capito che cosa dovevo fare
per raggiungere quei livelli ed è stata
lì da forza la forza vera con l'energia
necessaria che dovuto apprendere per
aspettare il mio momento quella chance e
la chance arriva mancano 9 minuti e il
mio allenatore con accento romanesco mi
chiama e mi dice dai e piccole
tocca a te la senti io senza proferire
parola
annuisco ma dentro il mio cuore batte i
tremila chilometri orari
entro inizio a correre su ogni pallone
fino a quando vedo una mia compagna che
lascia partire un tiro dalla distanza il
portiere trattiene corto mi fiondo
appoggio dentro la rete col un'emozione
indescrivibile lo stadio era pieno e
allora io inizio a correre all'impazzata
e prima di essere sommerso dalle mie
compagne penso a mio padre a mio padre
che in quel momento e in italia ma
vorrei tanto che fosse sugli spalti ed
essere orgoglioso di me sì perché
ricordo il giorno in cui mi portò per la
prima volta in un campo di calcio lo
fece con grandissima resistenza
all'epoca facevo pattinaggio artistico a
rotelle potete immaginare con tanto di
tutu e paillettes quindi proprio lo
stereotipo della femminilità ma quel
giorno mio padre
nonostante non fosse lì sapevo che era
orgoglioso di me e io provai un'emozione
incredibile e quell'emozione me la sono
portata dietro per tutto il resto della
mia carriera è stato il motivo per cui
ho basato tutta la mia carriera cercare
di rievocare quell'emozione sapere che
potevo lavorare
perseverare per aspettare quel momento
un'ulteriore chance e quell emozione
l'ho vissuta anche quel giorno allo
stadium lo rievocata e devo dire che il
calcio a me ha dato veramente veramente
tanto
ha insegnato molto insegnato il rispetto
la condivisione ma nei 28 anni che
separano questi due eventi ci sono tante
trasferte tanta fatica tanto sudore
tanta perseveranza vittorie sconfitte
cose comuni a tutti gli sportivi nel mio
sport c'è anche tanta lotta al
pregiudizio ai luoghi comuni
tanti anni spesi a cercare con le parole
e con i fatti di sradicare quella
convinzione e quel pensare comune
dell'inadeguatezza della donna alla
pratica di questo sport
beh devo dire che le cose adesso stanno
cambiando e mi viene in mente un
episodio poche settimane fa al termine
di una partita in contro una mia ex
compagna di nazionale che con gli occhi
sgranati nel vedere così tante bambine
intorno alle mie giocatrici per chiedere
un autografo
selphy rimane sbalordita e mi dice ma
quante cose son cambiate fisso è
pazzesco e tu sia ancora lì fa ancora
parte di questo mondo
e incredibile ed è una cosa bellissima
sì è vero forse non me ne rendo conto
sono ancora lì l'ho fatto con
naturalezza e vero le cose stanno
cambiando adesso le bambine hanno dei
modelli di riferimento a cui ispirarsi
anno le società professionistiche stanno
investendo stanno dando il loro supporto
così come gli sponsor e le aziende
investono il settore c'è persino chi ha
prodotto una bambola giocatrice è tutto
questo insieme ai successi della nostra
nazionale azzurra all'ultimo mondiale
hanno sicuramente dato una visibilità
diversa nutrito l'interesse di tutti beh
devo dire che
quel giorno allo stadium finalmente è
stata restituita la dignità
all'atleta alla donna ma anche al calcio
perché ho visto finalmente
intraprendersi un percorso sociale fatto
di uomini e donne che camminano verso la
stessa direzione
e allora ho rievocato anche una frase
scritta 20 anni prima da angelo caroli
in un suo scritto dedicato al calcio
femminile che diceva giorno verrà in cui
camminerete al sole e farete ombra
oggi quelle parole non sono più solo di
un visionario ma danno sicuramente luce
e speranza a un cambiamento e quindi se
si assume l'idea che il nostro futuro
parte della nostra storia
allora possiamo sicuramente affermare
che oggi le future generazioni hanno
terreno fertile per costruire e sognare
il loro futuro
grazie
[Applauso]